[Music]
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books back in 2003 a busy freelancer
named Mike McDormand I've actually had
dinner with accidentally saved over an
invoice and lost all of his work to make
sure that never happened again Mike set
out to create fresh books which is now
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals around the world that is
used by now 10 million plus folks in
total who need to send invoices get paid
fast and track their time a lot of you
fall in that category in September of
this year Mike and his entire team
relaunched an all-new version of their
platform built from the ground up double
down on what made a great in the first
place namely simplicity and speed so I
can't cover all the features in this
particular sponsor read but you can send
a branded invoice in under 30 seconds
you can see when a client is looked at
their invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support you will get a real
human being on the phone in three rings
or less and there are many other things
you can do take pictures of receipts on
your phone using their iOS mobile app
and makes expenses a million times
easier etc etc it is a rad service a lot
of you have recommended to me that's how
this came to be as a sponsorship so to
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial that means no credit card needed
and see how the brand-new FreshBooks can
change your freelancing game go to
FreshBooks com forward slash Tim and
enter Tim tee I am in the how did you
hear about a section that is first
ebooks.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec I reached out to these
innovative Finnish entrepreneurs of all
things because a very skilled Acrobat
introduced me to one of their products
which is a mushroom coffee made out of
chaga mushroom powerful antioxidant
considered a superfood I was introduced
to chaga by Laird Hamilton of all people
and another mushroom called lion's mane
which is considered a no tropic or a
smart drug and I had half a packet let
me put this in perspective tasted just
like coffee just add to hot water only
20 milligrams in half a packet of
caffeine that's as little as 1/10 what
you would find in a strong cup of coffee
and I was on fire for the entire day I
probably got more done in that day than
I got done in the 3 or 4 days prior to
that so I would highly recommend
checking it out it is very impressive
you will not see visuals so you can use
it for work and you can check it out at
4 sigma tech comm forward slash Tim
that's for sig Matic SI GM ATI c-calm
forward slash Tim and use the code Tim
to get 20% off your first order I highly
encourage you to try it out
hello ladies and germs reindeer and
elves crazy Bulgarians sitting across
from me that's a long story folks this
is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to sit down metaphorically or
physically with smart people excellent
people those who know what they're doing
in various worlds and he's out the
habits routines favorite books etc that
you can use and this time we did
something and that I'm usually allergic
to we actually talked about politics now
we did talk about how this gent lost 60
pounds we did talk about his ascension
into the ranks of the best respected
media companies in the world top 15
companies according to ink magazine
recently in the last week in fact I'm
talking about Ezra Klein and before you
cut bait and run because I said politics
realize that I never talk about politics
I feel like an ignoramus and that is by
design we don't talk about the T word
you don't talk about presidential stuff
we talk about how can you influence the
rules of the game by which this country
is run or your city or your state
because I've decided that it's time for
me to perhaps jump in and fray Ezra at
Ezra Klein on Twitter and other social
's like the facebook is founder and
editor-in-chief of voxcom an explanatory
news organization that now reaches more
than 100 million people each month
through articles videos newsletters and
podcasts before that first a previously
he was a columnist and editor at The
Washington Post a policy analyst and so
many acronyms a policy analyst at MSNBC
and a contributor to blur my god hey
crazy Bulgarian and - I need more
caffeine I think I do he was named one
of the 50 most powerful people in
Washington DC by GQ Esquire says he
quote gives economics columnist a good
name and quote which Azra hopes is a
hack curat he's written for The New
Yorker and the New York Review of Books
and his primary podcast as recline show
very very popular
a long-form interview show where he
talks to the smartest people he can find
including past guests like Bill Gates
what Rachel Maddow Andrew Sullivan Atul
Gawande I love to interview him to slack
founder Stewart Butterfield the Today
Show's Trevor Noah and many more
he also co-hosts the weeds a marsh maybe
it's weeds but the is lowercase so I'll
call it the weeds a weekly policy
podcast with his colleagues Matt
Iglesias and Sarah Kliff we talk about a
whole lot here it's a shorter episode
perhaps around an hour hour and fifteen
minutes and we cover a lot of ground so
I think you guys will enjoy it and this
really came from a personal place I have
opted out of political discussion for a
long time do not worry this podcast is
not going to turn into any type of
ranting machine really is very proactive
how do you influence policy if you don't
like well let's say sharks having their
fins cut off because someone granted
Chinese fishing rights to Costa Rica
what can you do that actually is
something that happened related to me or
if something you care about like a
startup or so anything is about to be
snuffed out by some questionable tactics
in a place like DC which happened to me
once or elsewhere what can you do and
turns out there are things that you can
do and this is this is about the tactics
and strategies you can use to not just
be a chess piece on the chessboard not
just to be a good chess player but
perhaps to actually change the rules of
chess so that you can stack the deck in
some respect that is it so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with Ezra client Ezra
welcome to the show thank you for having
me I always think that you live in New
York City which you do not but we happen
to come inside in this case I'm living
in New York City for today and I want to
set the tone or set the the visual for
people who are obviously not here
besides my imaginary friends at least I
am wearing a shirt that Jacque a wink
gave me and you can google him to figure
out who he is and it says know the
darkness and we're in a room in a hotel
that was set aside to be quiet and we
had to close the blinds so it is
literally dark
Flass romantic / romantic our hearts on
the wall we were in hipster penthouse
prison in New York City so the the
question that I really wanted to jump
into first and this may be an odd
jumping-off point but I had read that
you were bullied when you were a kid
yeah tell us about it because I really
don't have any of the details but I was
asked I've been asked a lot about
bullying recently and so I've been
exploring in my own head basically going
back as far as I consciously remember in
school I was the not an unpopular kid
but the the least popular kid and when I
was a kid I changed schools a number of
times because I was being bullied at
different places I changed it and went
back and when you do that by the way
something important about when you leave
one place because something is going
wrong then the same thing goes wrong so
you leave that place then you go back
and the same thing goes wrong is that
you do get a sense rightly or wrongly
that it is you and over time that really
wears you down so I want to be careful I
mean the bullying is not that I got the
[ __ ] kicked out of me every day but it
is that relentlessly I was teased or
mocked or kept out of things I had my
stuff hidden I mean it's very sort of
common kid stuff but it is a painful way
to grow up
one of the things about that experience
which I would say lasted more or less
into mid high school for me and then a
lot of things change for me and we can
we can talk about what they were but was
that it gave me a real appreciation of
the way context decides people's lives
because in a lot of context when I was
young a party I think for me in the
school context which really didn't fit
for me things went very badly I failed
at everything it wasn't by the way just
that I was being bullied I also did a
terrible job in school I barely
graduated I barely got into college
and then when I was able to change the
context of my life later on change it in
college change it with blogging change
it by going into journals and by moving
to Washington DC my life transformed
really dramatically
and that too was a bit of a lesson where
I had to find a place a context where
the qualities that I have were adaptive
rather than maladaptive that wasn't
school but it but it did exist let's dig
into that a little bit when you were
going from place to place what did you
think at the time was wrong with you or
what were you routinely teased for so a
bunch of things so I was very heavy
growing up I was so I weighed in my
sophomore year of high school 60 pounds
more than I do now to give a number on
it so one just being fat as a kid gets
you bullied maybe not in every case but
certainly in a lot I would not say I was
a practically great dresser although
although one thing I will say on that is
I did as part of my trying to get away
from this go to a school for a couple
years it had a dress code not that I
thought that was the issue that didn't
really help anything so clearly that was
not the area variable right but I was
not a great dresser I am a sort of
loquacious argumentative person yeah and
I think that the edges of that were
probably even harsher when I was young
and stranger in the context in which
they were applied right so it's one
thing to be a bit of an argumentative
person when you work in journalism and
politics it's another thing to do it in
elementary school so that probably
didn't help another thing though that
when I look back if I could have I'm not
sure I would change my life because I
like how it's worked out but if I if I
were giving advice to my younger self
something that I didn't do something
that I I do regret is it I didn't go and
find and take comfort in spaces it might
have been more natural to me so that
wasn't really possible I think in
elementary school by the time I was in
high school I was I didn't leave the
situation and find another which is to
say I didn't go into theater or go into
try to work for the school newspaper or
do things that would put me in a context
that was maybe a little more suited to
me instead I tried to be on the football
team I was a I was on the football team
I was a wrestler I was really trying to
find acceptance and so I kept also
budding my budding myself into the
situation
that put me at risk is in exactly the
word but but in in space where this
would happen that isn't to blame myself
for it but it is to say that I don't
think I almost somehow understood that I
had choices right and so I didn't make
any it had become in my head as if the
only option was to succeed in this one
context that was repeatedly and
continuously rebuffing me mm-hmm now the
so the word contacts is something I want
to want to define for folks in this
particular case in this instance I'm not
gonna do it I'm gonna ask you to do it
but is that simply choosing where you
are who you surround yourself with
basically the interrogatives of a
journalism if you were to answer those
for yourself is that the context that
you then created for yourself in college
later is that what you mean by context
yeah I think I mean a lot of things by
it but I mean the situation you're in so
let me use an on bullying example I
mentioned that I did poorly in school
and I really did I'm not one of these
kids who's who's coming here and saying
oh I had a 3.5 in high school and you
know but everybody else had a four point
I graduated high school to 2.2 I failed
out a lot of classes I was in remedial
math by the end and I've done a lot of
thinking about why that was and I really
think that I had a basically a learning
disability I have a tremendous amount of
trouble absorbing information from
someone lecturing if you put me even now
when I'm older and more disciplined and
have much more reason to absorb the
information that is coming at me as a
journalist I basically won't call into a
teleconference call because I just know
I can't absorb anything and so I would
spend all day sitting in this classroom
where somebody was talking at me and I
just couldn't I couldn't focus on it I
couldn't absorb any of it and because
there is this cultural message in
America where when you see kids in
school on television everybody's always
doodling and daydreaming and you know
thinking about something else and I mean
that's the the meme about it so I
thought everybody was actually doing
what I was doing and never ever under
any circumstances paying attention for
even two minutes
and that wasn't true obviously other
people were paying attention they were
taking notes they didn't know what the
hell was going on when they looked at
their homework later when I went to
college college doesn't really ask that
of you you don't really have to attend
class if you don't want to you can read
the book and then you can write an essay
there are other ways for me of absorbing
information that I am much better than
average at I'm really really good at
absorbing information in conversation
I'm really good at absorbing information
from reading and so the extent that I
could be in a place where I could do
that I could actually succeed
academically and so it was the
difference between those I was the same
person but in one the particular set of
strengths and weaknesses I had led me to
be one of the worst performers and in
another the exact same set of strengths
and weaknesses put me I wasn't the best
performer in college but I was I did
very well and that to me was so a big
lesson what was your what was your major
in college policy that makes sense you
know I wish I hadn't done it
even though nowadays I love Political
Science it is and at the core of my work
and I think among journalists I am
unusually focused on it as a way of
understanding American politics I had a
lot of trouble in college understanding
how it related I was already doing
political writing then and I just
somehow didn't click and I do wish I had
spent that time learning about a
discipline or a topic that I did not
plan to go into so if I could go back I
think I would have been a philosophy
major a surprising number of people I've
interviewed on this podcast we're ended
up being philosophy majors it's it's
which I've been I think is an excellent
choice and I get asked a lot because of
my proximity to say the teal fellowship
well I should say rather my proximity
geographically to Silicon Valley and a
very anti College sentiment or
romanticizing quite a bit what kids
should do or parents sometimes ask me
about what they should do as it relates
to college and their kids and the only
answer I've been able to come up with
that I've been reasonably happy with is
that the goal of a liberal arts
education is to make you well-rounded
human being not to prepare you for maybe
to equip you with the meta skills but
not to prepare you necessarily for a
specific trade
and the the the follow-up that I want to
ask was you went from elementary school
high school not realizing that you
didn't have to accept option a in front
of you you had other choices like you
said where's there a moment when you
realized a specific conversation or it
something your parents had to do
anything in college we said oh wait a
second I can actually pass or do well in
this class by simply writing the essays
and taking the tests and I can choose
the type of information the format that
I absorb yeah so let me say a couple
things here one is that I was lucky and
privileged to have other choices so my
family wasn't rich by any means but my
father's a university professor and so
the SATs were a thing in my household I
my parents could pay for me to go to a
prep course which I also had trouble
paying attention to but but nevertheless
so I do want to say one thing here which
is that I'm very conscious that the
second chances I got not everybody would
have gotten sometimes if for a lot of
people if you don't do well in high
school that's just it for you you get
tracked into something very very
different and I was lucky I did well on
I had always taken tests very well it's
something I'm you know just good at and
that got me into the UC system I also
was lucky to be in a state California
that has a great college public college
system and you sees at least at that
point had something called eligibility
where if you got a it was a sliding
scale GPA and SATs but if you got above
a 1400 on your SATs you got into Santa
Cruz or UC Riverside just automatically
and I was able to do that so I went to
Santa Cruz which is great but but so
that's one thing having having those
choices isn't always fully under your
control but the other thing is that I
don't think there was an epiphany moment
and to some degree I wasn't shocked it
wasn't that I thought I was dumb I knew
I was a good writer and I knew that I
was actually pretty smart I could talk
to people about things during high
school and and even before that I was a
pretty voracious self learner and so
when I got to a place where I could
actually choose what I was learning
about which I also think is a
non-trivial
mention of this being able to say I want
to learn about politics I see the
relevance of it to my life as opposed to
and now you're in chemistry and that is
in to downgrade chemistry actually at
this point wish I knew a lot more about
chemistry but I had thought that would
work a bit better for me and and so I
wasn't shocked when it did I can help me
with the chemistry but surely Breaking
Benjamin type of ad hoc experimentation
which is probably not what you're
looking for
you mentioned in a high school not
writing for the school paper
correct you were trying to do football
wrestling and so on at some point you
did try to write for school paper Christ
and a cruise city on a hill press man
all right I've heard of it I've heard of
it I'm a subscriber no it's not true but
what happened how'd that go
I got nothing happened the whole story
there is nothing happened
I got to Santa Cruz which is an awesome
awesome place by the way and even just
able to visit panic College is wasted on
the young
10 degrees is this place where it is
built in a redwood grove I may get the
exact details of this wrong but no
building is allowed to be higher than
2/3 of the height of the tallest nearby
redwood so everything is just dominated
by these amazing trees and this amazing
land is just this phenomenal grant of
land there are their dorm rooms in Santa
Cruz that have a redwood and Ocean View
dorm rooms
so as for Santa Cruz is great and I yeah
I just got in there I was trying to
figure out what I would be doing or what
I wanted to be doing and I applied to
work at City on Hill Press which is the
student newspaper and it I just got
rejected which was not strange I mean I
didn't do the student newspaper in high
school I had no obvious aptitude in that
I will say though it is there are
different ways you can frame the story
of your life one of them is through the
things you achieved
it often feels to me that the true one
for me or at least in as true one is
through the things that I wanted and
didn't get that turned out to be extreme
blessings so at about the same time I
applied for Santa Cruz City on hill
press I don't know why I just said that
so formally the student newspaper I'm
sold I'm sold it's still it has this
vaunted space in my imagination I had
started but at that point was an unknown
thing which was a blog we were right in
the beginning of the early political
blogosphere this is 2003 before you
tried to uh ha pitch the press I was
bored I went to Santa Cruz and is great
but I was a college kid and I just
didn't have that much to do so I had
begun reading some of these bloggers and
in particular there was a kid at another
college across the country named Matt
Iglesias who had a really good blog that
I really liked
what was it about politics and it was
just this super smart analytical Harvard
student writing about politics
and it become pretty again in the early
blogosphere pretty central blog it was
him this guy named Kevin drum who was
actually in my hometown of Irvine
California but but I looked at mad and I
thought well if this college kid can
have a blog event then maybe I can but
if I got in into city on a hill I'm sure
I would have just done that right it
would have been much more absorbing
would have had a big big social
component the people I know who did
student newspaper work they really got
into it but I didn't get that was always
a panic - I've nobody ever told me was a
big deal for them in life I think I just
didn't get it okay good
but if that left me with a lot of time
to focus on on blogging which at that
moment didn't at all seem like a good
trade nobody in 2003 thought blogging
was going to be a pathway into
journalism or into anything else nobody
even knew the word but turned out to be
it arguably the central pivot moment in
my life how much time did you spend on
it and the when I took to that it's
funny because we talked about context
changes before but the real context
change for me wasn't high school to
college it was high school to blogging
when I found that
something happened to me where I was
writing I wasn't writing for a big
audience I had um by 2004 let's say what
year of college would that be this would
be going into my sophomore year sometime
by 2004 I was getting I think 35 readers
a day and I think that I cared more
about those 35 rooters a day then I have
ever cared I mean I love the audience
but I felt so amazed that 35 people and
on some days when I got him at Iglesias
like a hundred and fifty people would
come to the site it blew me away
and when I found that when I found this
space for what I could do was read what
I was interested in and then process it
through writing and that that's an
important thing for me because going
back to this idea of how do you absorb
information I'm good at absorbing it by
reading but the real way I come up with
ideas is by talking about a writing
about what I have definitely uh-huh the
inputs let's at Kevin Kelley a founding
editor of Wired says to says I I write
to find out what I'm thinking I think
that's a Joan Didion line
ya know blow up Kevin Kelley's spot here
I may actually be misappropriating a
quote attributed to Kevin but he
elaborates obviously but it's something
like I don't know what I think until I
start writing you know that's deeply
true and I found blogging and you know
again I'm writing for 15 then 30 then 45
people a day and I just took it from the
beginning I just got addicted like
really addicted it was a little blogspot
blog and I would wake up at 7 in the
morning as a college student and be
writing blog post so that my East Coast
audience all nine of them had something
to read I was writing and in college I
was writing 15 things a day on the blog
Wow I barely ever partied to impart cuz
I still actually I did not figure things
out socially for a couple years littell
a couple years later still so I didn't
have many friends when did you lose your
weight sophomore year of high schools
around scent of high school of high
school that was a big turning point in
my life - how did you lose the weight
what was the trigger also I got rejected
by a girl I really liked yes so that was
a trigger this is a perennial so I had
the option to
to absorb that as I am NOT a likable
person or you know not a lovable person
or you know this beautiful girl didn't
want to be with me because I'm heavy
uh and I I'm not saying correctly by the
way I don't want to suggest that as an
objective view of the reality but that
it was a way I absorbed it but it was a
choice between hue ejected me for
reasons or due to factors I can't change
or due to factors I can yeah and and
this was the the face-saving way to do
it and so something kind of clicked
there I'm not really sure what or why
but for six months I ate the exact the
exact same thing every day and I ran
three miles a day
would you eat I'd I have to I'm gonna
try to remember this I woke up and I ate
a what did I oh I two eggs with salsa
for breakfast every day and then at
10:00 a.m. buildings no they were just
like fried oak and I was not a good cook
right fried eggs salsa I had not read
the 4-hour chef so fried eggs with salsa
and then at 10:00 a.m.
whenever sort of break was at my call at
my high school I had a pure protein bar
which I still eat those today but back
then that those tasted like garbage let
me tell ya of just let me be real clear
of shock and a I don't know why this was
what it was but a mini Bob Lee pizza
crust with two slices of deli meat
turkey on it okay
I'm quickly running out of remembering I
don't remember what I did for lunch
actually I would get home and I think
had a speck of popcorn usually and then
I would microwave to Lean Cuisines for
dinner
that was what I ate every day how did
you decide on that particular regime
there was some way that actually
happened I had been told I went inside I
think I went and talked to a trainer at
the gym I got like a free trainer thing
you know like you can go and have a
consult at a gym and you told me like
how many calories I should be eating and
I just literally figured out a count to
get there and then I didn't stop I I
don't think I could do that today I
don't really know where that came
in May but it happened and that was that
was also the first time in my own life
that I had been able to take control of
something and really succeeded it and a
lot of confidence emerged from that for
me because until then there were a lot
of things about me that just seemed to
be immutable they were how I was and
then all of a sudden it turned out that
that wasn't how I was that was just how
I been until I made a series of changes
and out of that I've become in my life
and in my attitude towards life probably
obsessively calibrating and hopefully
self improving but I'm I always have you
know and I'm talking to somebody that I
don't know anything about that
but I always have sort of three or four
things that I'm constantly trying to
track and change and play with because
it just gave me a real sense that you
are who you make yourself to be there
are a few things I want to highlight see
you figure it out a number of things in
high school and then in college one of
which was do I have to pay for this
therapy session or for since there's an
intro first one spring the one of which
was the the format of information that
you absorb best and what would I want to
just mention for people is that this is
a critical piece of the puzzle to figure
out so I was chatting with Ed Catmull
president Pixar his book creativity Inc
yeah an amazing amazing tastic book and
he had in a sense the exact opposite
experience that you had so he found that
he could not absorb he was trying to
read and I'm making up this example
would say the Odyssey or any type of
poetry or anything that actually began
with being transmitted as an oral
tradition he couldn't absorb it on in
print and he started listening and so
that is you in the exact opposite
direction and started listening to I
think it was the Teaching Company while
he was on commutes to absorb information
well actually it's it's funny related to
that something I have learned later in
life is that I can absorb information
from listening extremely well if it is
the secondary thing I'm doing
so I cannot sit I actually cannot sit at
my computer and watch a TED talk I can't
do it but I can listen to a podcast
while I walk my dogs or clean my house
or whatever and so I absorb now
particularly because I have less time to
read because of my job has more of a
management schedule I absorb a
tremendous amount of information through
podcasting while I am doing other things
and I don't know why that makes it
possible for me but it somehow does
similarly in my office at work I have a
lot of trouble paying attention during
meetings so my office is littered with
things that I can play with my hands
it's just full of squeeze balls and
magnets and I just every so often just
go on Amazon and search fidget toys and
I will buy any fidget toy I can find and
it's full of them and people think oh
you have this quirky little office and
the actual reason is that I can pay
attention much better if I'm absorbed
physically somewhere else
it makes me think I have know why this
flashed in mind but you've seen the
movie big with Tom and I have the one
that's one of his first meetings and
they walk in when he's at the toy
company he's crashing these cars
together as they're trying to talk to
but let's flash forward to the present
for just a moment and then we'll
backtrack again and so the first is what
are what do you have you listen to most
say in the last year in terms of before
you just fishing for compliments no no
no I didn't like 20 but he doesn't I
need to I need to tip hundreds with it
so I'm a fan of your show so I can
actually pull out my podcast list here
yes way to check it out
oh of course I always listen to the Ezra
Klein show and the weeds the two
greatest non Tim Ferriss podcasts in
American life today so podcast I like
listening to are like your show I'm a
big fan of you made it weird
the Pete Holmes podcast which is just a
great interview I like the long-form
podcast reply all reco decode Kara
Swisher who's part of Vox media as a
great interview show practically in the
election season I listen to a lot of the
acts files which was David Axelrod's is
David Axelrod's interview show it's
great that's a good one off message by
Glen thrush I think is good that's a
political show I love
with Tyler Cohen Tyler is brilliant he's
a guy I know well I've actually been on
that show with him and he just has a
mind that works unlike any mind I've
ever come into contact with before he's
made his mind different he is a polymath
in a truer sense so I'll just give you
example from when I was on his show we
were talking about the conversation in
America about diversity and inclusion
and tolerance and pluralism and
multiculturalism right it's up a Trump
campaign related conversation and Tyler
who knows that during my honeymoon I
went to Singapore for two days and knows
that I'm half Brazilian so I've been to
Brazil a lot says well Brazil and
Singapore have such different
conversations about multiculturalism and
diversity when you look at the way they
experience these issues versus America
do you think they've figured something
out that we haven't and embedded in that
question is one that Tyler is so smart
that he actually has a distinct point of
view about the discourse around
multiculturalism in Singapore but also
thinks other people might also have a
view so just listening to him is a real
tour through somebody who is smarter of
the mind of somebody who's smarter than
you are
I love death sex and money that's a
great show just makes me also think we
just did a photographer but so my
conversations with Eric Weinstein he's
the managing director of teal capital
but he's I don't know why he was coming
up so much but the he's a he's a
mathematician and physicist and he'll
say something like well of course you
know what a mirror orchid is and it okay
and it'll just continue back that's not
gonna fight but I switched on pop is
great by Charlie Manning and Nate I'm
blanking out his house name but it's a
good pop culture podcast so either you
live in vast selection of podcasts I
know a lot of people get overwhelmed
with input maybe they just feel like
there's too much to read too much to
listen to house phone it by Ben Thompson
I like that one how do you choose how do
you choose which is come up they you you
look at what it's come up easy what's
interesting I actually find most days I
don't have one I want to listen to I
it's not that everything every episode
of every one of these podcasts is
interesting to me
hopefully there are enough sitar so what
is interesting and I'll catch that it's
probably not properties of the word but
in the question not about all the ones I
didn't mention no there's that there
were there were a lot there if you had
to give a not listen to TED talk would
give a TED talk on something that you're
not known for at all so no politics
something that you are very interested
in that is is not something people
readily associate you with something
maybe you read about on the weekends or
evenings whatever it is what would that
be what might you talk about it would
probably be about some angle on the
ethics of meat-eating which I feel real
strongly about mm-hmm and and not not
simply eating meat is bad yeah but one
thing that I become really convinced by
and I've become convinced by a guy named
Bruce Friedrich who's actually on my
podcast and said this to me I've been
thinking about it ever since
so one I think what we eat is a very
profound moral choice and and I've
argued and I do believe elsewhere that
50 years from now 100 years from now
when it's really easy to not eat factory
farm meat because there's all this
lab-grown meat and and really tasty
synthetic meat people will look back on
the way we treated animals in this era
and judge us very very harshly agree
with that I think we are gonna look very
bad because you know work we're
torturing a lot of sentient beings
constantly and but that said one thing
that I I've become convinced buys it if
you want I don't think that it is good
that the only ways here you can be
quote-unquote ethical is to become a
vegetarian or a vegan one I think it's
just too hard for a lot of people to
it's actually not the right way to think
about what you're trying to do here
you're not being consequentialist enough
about it if we get everybody to cut meat
consumption by half that is so much
better than quadrupling the number of
vegetarians from I think it's roughly
around 5% now to where it would go so
one I think we need to be thinking just
really about reduction here but the
thing that Bruce explained to me which I
haven't thought about a lot before was
that people think that what they should
do is go vegetarian and that's actually
not a great equilibrium in two
animal suffering because particularly
because egg-laying chickens are arguably
the worst treated of all of the animals
so if you've cut out a lot of other
kinds of meat and you're eating a lot of
eggs there are some contexts in which
you're buying backyard eggs from a
farmer I mean you can come up with the
examples here where the animals treated
really really well and great if you're
able to source like that god bless you
but I think a lot of people have ended
up a little bit accidentally in spaces
where they've maybe cut out red meat so
eating a lot of chicken but it turns out
you can finish a chicken in a night it
takes a family of four like a year or
two years to finish a cow and and what
Bruce who used to run campaigns for PETA
and now does investing around I think he
likes to call it clean meat
what would he argued to me was if
everybody just ate beef cut out eggs cut
out poultry cut out fish cut out all the
rest of it everybody just eat beef you
would reduce the number of animals
killed for human consumption by
something in the order of 95 to 98
percent so it actually really matters
how big the animal is and cows because
you do need to raise them for all
they're actually treated even the ones
not treated well better particular
butter than chickens and other kinds of
poultry there's no effort really any
word to figure out a humane way to raise
and kill fish because we just don't jump
the species barrier and sympathy that
way so and I do know they're people I
think this guy named Matt ball I think
his organization is called first step
and I've been if I have that wrong all
I'll send it to you for your show notes
who's been making a similar argument so
this is very much not my argument but I
think that it would not be that hard for
a lot of people to switch over to beef
consumption and to go from there now I
do want to say there's cross-cutting
environmental concerns people argue
about whether a pound of beef is
significantly worse for the environment
than a pound of chicken or fish I have
heard that both ways I've not looked
into it enough to know right now I'm
confined what I'm saying is just about
animal suffering yeah it's this is I we
could talk about this for a long time I
have read quite about quite a bit of on
both sides of the fence
if you will just don't need the meat
eating versus non mediating if we're
looking at in a binary fashion
and what's been philosophically
interesting for me at least to hear and
listen to are the how the reasons
dictate what you consume on the less
meat side of the equation so you have
people who are say optimizing for number
of animals killed then you have people I
have some distinction in cognitive
ability that determines what they'll eat
or not and then there's the the carbon
say emissions component which i think is
actually kind of falls apart with cows
in the sense that they're often on
grazing lands that couldn't otherwise be
utilized for a many agrarian purposes
but then you run into all these thorny
things and I'm not going to get into
like deep Peter Singer land but the if
you look at some of the mono crops so
for instance you were mentioning how the
with an incomplete information if you're
trying to minimize suffering in the
total number of animals if you go
lacto-ovo vegetarian and suddenly you're
quadrupling your egg intake that you
might be in fact net netting on the side
of doing more damage than just saying
having one cow or a quarter of a cow and
with the mono cops so and so on if you
look at the threshers and then comfort
of animals they end up killing these
small rodents and whatnot then it just
becomes a very complex moral decision or
it seems that it can become a very
nuanced I should say moral decision I'm
not super convinced by the mono crop
thrush or arguments at least feel to me
a little bit like an argumentative move
they're meant to paralyze the
conversation mmm in a place of
information abundance right it's true
that we can never have perfect knowledge
about all the consequences of our
decisions but I think this is one where
people's moral intuitions here are
pretty clear and actually should be
followed I just never meet anybody who
says yeah a factory farming is okay no
no and but I will sometimes be people
who say and I'm not saying you're doing
this here who begin bringing a level of
what what about this well what about
that and and it's true but it would be
wonderful if we all decided to treat the
way we eat as enough of an ethical
choice that we're actually trying to get
there that information and are in a
really strong way but but I think that
people can make I think the important
thing to me and the thing that I've
thought a lot about in my own life is
people can make moves that are not that
painful that appear with our best
knowledge to have a really big
first-order effect on on suffering and
that and that it's worth doing and that
the the sort of equilibrium of it just
being about vegetarianism or veganism I
think has probably made this a lot
harder because it's just hard for folks
to make jumps that big
yeah the adherence is really low right
so if you're trying to move the needle
it's it's I think about this a lot as it
relates to behavioral change just since
I've thought about it and spent so much
time with people who are studying this
in labs the you run into this conundrum
with say very strict vegans or very
strict paleo for that matter if you try
to take someone from zero to 60 from
standard American diet to either of
those science the the drop off that
you're gonna have is gonna probably be
above 90 percent after a few weeks and
then what absolutely good have you
accomplished it's it's a lot easier to
get people say one step further it's
like hey try moving to this protein and
consuming if eat either fewer eggs or
really paying attention specifically to
how you're sourcing and it's an
interesting thing there there there's a
fair amount of behavioral science
evidence that it's important to people
to act in ways reasonably consonant with
the identities they have for themselves
and so something I found because I
flitted back and forth between
vegetarianism and not for a long time
and now I've had been pretty de been in
for a bit but was that what would happen
is I would say I'm going vegetarian and
then at some point I would fail and
having failed it's not like what would
happen is that I would go to 95%
vegetarian I would completely collapse
back into full-on in omnivore ISM and
the the reason in part was that if I had
set up the success structure such that I
was vegetarian or I was not then was not
is almost the same kind of failure
no matter how much meat I was eating
what kind of meat out of his eating all
of it and so the way this actually stuck
for me this time was that the way I went
vegetarian a couple of years ago now was
with a tremendous number of caveats I'm
vegetarian except when I travel because
I know when I travel I often have a lot
of trouble sticking to vegetarianism so
if I'm vegetarian except when I travel
and when they travel then I eat meat
well then it doesn't offend my identity
at all and now I'm I'm mostly vegan I'm
vegan at home except when I travel I'm
vegetarian and there are a couple points
in the year it's like my best friend's
mother I've been having sushi with her
since I was a kid and it is important to
me that I am able to continue that
tradition and so as opposed to going and
having sushi there twice a year and then
collapsing out of all of my other eating
habits because of it it's just that's
built into it that's our exception today
and and so I've actually found that
personally very helpful to create to not
be so strict on myself that when I make
decisions that I can pretty well predict
I'm gonna make that they have this
identity collapsing effect on me so
let's let's take a left turn and go back
to college what were some of the I don't
sound enough like a Santa Cruz banana
slug to you no I'm enjoying that I'm
we've got that much of a left turn no I
yes I had a lot of step back to it back
to the ardent of life did you ever get a
garden of life in Santa Cruz back to
back to Santa Cruz and a very good
writing school and people playing
didgeridoos in the street what were the
decisions or lucky incidents that really
defining moments once you started the
blog when did you go from 35 okay if you
got a lucky link 150 when did when did
that start to change couple key things
happened so one is I mentioned this
other college kid so that's Matt
Iglesias and Matt is my co-founder at
Vox we work together now and actually
have worked together for a lot of our
adult lives also at the American
Prospect and is in a very important way
my mentor but he was
he continuously as someone with a bigger
site linked to me sent people to my site
and the patronage I think is actually a
fair term for it the attention to
someone I respected that much was a
tremendous kind of positive feedback for
me how did he find your site emailed him
okay
very early on I emailed it to him and
and he linked to it he was very generous
wouldn't want to say in your email oh
god I genuinely don't remember
was it a picture was it I'm at love your
stuff like I think it was hi Matt I love
your stuff I think it's probably hi Matt
I love your stuff I've also started a
blog where I'm saying things that are
gonna prove to be wildly incorrect and
embarrassing about American politics
although I probably didn't say that at
the time that did however prove out to
be the truth of it um but I started a
blog also you might I'd love to if you
checked it out and he checked it out so
that was really important and and I
remember I mean in my earliest I
remember it took me I think a year and a
half maybe more to get my first Kevin
drum link my first Kevin drum link was a
big deal to me Andrew Sullivan I think
came later even than that and the blocks
her then was small I mean it was a
personal place there was insta pundit
who was the big link aggregator on the
right and had be you know the sort of
Warhawk right and you had a trios who
was the big linker on the left and it
sort of went on like that so I did
pretty assiduously try to get my stuff
in front of those people for a period of
time and all that mattered to me that
escalating series of accomplishments hey
I finally achieved a Kevin drum like now
I've really made it really matter to me
I went and did a I'll back up a little
bit here the reason I started a
political blog is that I was in to
politics reason I was into politics is
my brother who lives in Los Angeles and
is an environmental attorney out there
was also into politics and was
incredibly incredibly insanely generous
to his fat socially awkward
twelve-year-old brother and when he did
political work in LA wit would take me
along and I'll never forget and will
never stop being grateful
during the bit during bill Bradley's two
in campaign for the presidency my
brother was driving around Senator Paul
Wellstone the late Senator Paul
Wellstone is an amazing figure in
American politics he died in a plane
crash I think it was in 2002 and my
brother had this opportunity my brother
at this point must have been 26
something like that 28 he's a lot older
than I am and he had the opportunity to
drive Wellstone and his wife around la
for a day and he had me come with him
and I I can't I still almost can't
believe that moment here's my brother
Gideon who has this opportunity as a
young up-and-coming Politico to spend a
whole day with a US senator like that's
a real opportunity I think most people
would take that opportunity for
themselves and to spend that time trying
to press the senator with how smart they
are and and he took me and I spent that
day talking with Paul Wellstone about
wrestling because Wellstone was a high
school and college was such a great
magic trick wrestling is a great
connector continue so but I was into
politics and I started a blog because I
interests to ask two things for those
people quite frankly myself who were
wondering because I have always had
maybe the the exact opposite inclination
I developed mostly due to family but who
talked a lot about politics all the
timing on two huge fights I developed an
allergy to it but I never really knew
what in the first place they meant by
politics what is politics when you say
an interest in politics was that mean I
was interested in the decisions
politicians were making to move power
resources and personnel into different
spaces in the American and international
space so in this era I graduated high
school in 2002 so the year before I
graduated is 9/11 and 9/11 was a moment
that certainly woke me to the idea that
politics cared about me even if I didn't
care about it hmm we were starting wars
which and I think people forget this
there is talk at that time of a draft
and in some ways I think arguably there
were good arguments for one that at
least would have made us as a country
think hard about where we were going to
war and whether or not we all wanted to
bear that that sacrifice but I was I
think that the reason I got engaged in
politics I mean my my family talked
about it but it wasn't it's I don't come
from a political family I think the
reason that I got engaged in politics
was it was a very very political time
and I found those questions to be
enormous ly interesting and and
obviously obviously consequential I'm
not sure that if I had been in this
formative period of my life in 1996 I
would have found it as obviously
consequential I'm not sure it was as
obviously consequential because this is
actually the timeframe that I was in
when at the period of time in which I
sort of came of age
I think of 2000 I actually thought it
wouldn't have calmed down and now it
looks like it's ramping back up but
politics got a lot more central to the
lives of most people starting in roughly
2001 we've had since then a period of
time that when the history of this era
is written they are not gonna spend much
time on the Clinton years
they're not gonna spend much time on the
George HW Bush years that that era is
going to be interesting for the rise of
China the dissolution of the Soviet
Union but it's not going to be
interesting for what happened in America
but starting with 9/11 going through the
financial crisis now the election of
Trump we are a country that is I had a
history professor I transferred to UCLA
my junior year and I had history
professor there who said I don't know if
you know this but the grip the fist of
history is tightening around all of you
right now and I've always remembered
that because I think it's true she meant
that this is a moment that is capital H
history hmm this is a moment that when
people write about the 21st century
they're not gonna skip over a moment
when America is going to war when
there's talk of a clash of this was in
2000 and probably three or four or may a
little later this is what America's
going to war people are talking about
clash of civilizations I mean it was a
moment that felt like history
and similar to you know we have reshaped
the framework of the American social
state we created a near universal health
care guarantee in America for the first
time now we're talking about whether or
not we're gonna dissolve that just a
couple years after it was launched these
this doesn't happen all the time this is
not the velocity at which politics
normally operates in this country really
any other so if we go back to then your
exploration and she said turned out
largely inaccurate on the blog in the
early days was there a piece that first
felt you made that you'd cracked through
and I remember for instance the first
post on my blog that ever at the time
reached the front page of Digg and I
crashed my site immediately but that was
a big deal when did when did you crack
out of or what was the first piece that
really you remember the first piece that
really probably don't actually but I'll
give a different version of one I knew
maybe something was beginning to happen
here and it's a fairly funny story
actually so in 2004 or maybe this is
2003 but it's the run-up to the 2004
election and things feel very
consequential Bush is a very polarizing
president I was at the University of
Santa Cruz you can imagine we decided
that polarization I was on and there's a
lot of talk in the blogosphere a lot of
talk to some people about who should run
against him now I very idiosyncratically
had become obsessed with a long retired
politician by the name of Gary Hart who
I had read and I cannot recommend this
book highly enough
Richard Ben Kramer a great great
journalist who died an unfortunate
couple years ago he wrote a book a
mammoth book about the 1988 election
which is considered one of the landmark
books in New Journalism just the way it
is written is extraordinary what is the
New Journalism New Journalism was a way
of doing nonfiction journalism using the
techniques of literary fiction at least
the more modern techniques of literary
fiction and I want to say I'm not an
expert on this so there's probably much
more precise definition but people like
Tom Wolfe and Norman Mailer and Richard
Ben Kramer it was a way of writing about
world as it happened but with a
informality and an experimental style
that you'd really only seen in fiction
until then I do want to say actually
that these things these books these
changes in language and how you talk
about things these are actually really
important to people more so than I think
folks realize one reason I got into
blogging is I remember coming across a
blog post where somebody I don't know
how old the person was but it was
clearly young wrote about American
politics and used the word props to say
that somebody was doing something good
right props to them it sounds dumb but
it actually hit me like a thunderbolt
the idea that you could talk about
politics not in the language that George
Will talked about it on the Washington
Post op-ed page or that people talked
about Island crossfire on CNN or that
Paul Krugman talked about it the the
idea that you could talk about it in the
language that you just talked it seems
so obvious now because now so many
people do it but it wasn't then it's one
of the really big things blogging
contributed was a breakdown and
experimentation with tone a political
tone was very formal and mannered and
structured and it's much more opened up
now including out very big institutions
that previously had a much more mannered
formal structured tone so that that
matters to me but but Ben Kramer he
wrote this book and this book is just X
to remember the title what it takes what
it takes yes the book is called what it
takes everybody should read it and Gary
Hart is really the hero what it takes he
is the person who he's brought down by
sexual scandal and a scandal by the way
that seems in the era of grabbed them by
the [ __ ] so unbelievably minimal
so Gary Hart comes out as he here of
what it takes and Hart has a lot of
fascinating dimensions to him but one of
the fascinating dimensions to him he's
very early through a commission he
co-chaired with with another Senator
Warren Rudman I think Warren Rudman
at seeing the threats that were gonna be
coming the threats from terrorism from
non-state actors the way the American
military needed to reorganize to meet
those hypothesis what is a non-state
actor a non-state actors how al-qaeda's
a non-state actor so previously the
Soviet Union versus America is two
states going to war with each other al
Qaeda or Isis and america are america
and non-state actors understood which
have very very different their different
ways you need to organize yourself to
deal with non-state actors so Hart had
had been pretty visionary on this and
with somebody who seemed like at a time
when Democrats needed a national
security voice he had actually had
enough of a claim depressions here that
he might be a strong candidate so hart
actually begins to thinking about
running for president that year and I
somehow get signed up with an
organization for him that doesn't yet
exist
and I am an intern in this shadow Gary
Hart organization and heart is heart is
testing the water so I have now set up
in Northern California a couple of
events for him one in I think one in
Oakland and one in San Francisco or is
some may be his one in I think maybe is
one in Palo Alto and one in San
Francisco and I am driving him and this
is so great so I have my little blog I
am the blogosphere so only heart
supporter certainly the only heart
supporter who is under the age of 20
that anybody has met recently and I am
writing about him and now I'm driving
this guy around and it's just so so
[ __ ] exciting but I'm not an
experienced planner of political events
and certainly not experienced in
logistics of getting up to and from them
so these events are not that far apart
from each other either in time or in
space I'm driving heart around I had a
blue Ford Focus with a stick shift and I
had never driven in San Francisco at all
and definitely not in San Francisco
traffic
and so I'm taking a heart from Palo Alto
to San Francisco and we are super late
because it's at rush hour and so it's
not taking however long it would have
taken but taken three times that long
and we are on these hills and I'm
burning out the transmission on every
one of them so the car is filled with
this acrid stench of the destruction of
the undercarriage of this vehicle some
of these ills would be belonging to San
Francisco I mean they they feel like
they're 45 degrees and they're vertical
and he is understandably not unkindly
getting agitated at one point he asks if
I would like him to drive eventually get
him there all the events themselves went
fine but it was it was an unpleasant
experience for everybody involved it was
stressful it was the next day he
announces he is not ready for it
oh it's probably not but I've always
wondered if he was like I am too old for
this [ __ ] I do not need idiot kids
burning out their transmissions gonna be
late but like I just that's not what I
that's not the life I need to lead as a
human being but so Gary Hart drops out
and I write on my blog which again 35
people day at this point then I'm really
bummed by the candidate I support it is
not in the race anymore I get an email
from Joe Trippi who is the campaign
manager for Howard Dean's campaign and
Howard Dean's campaign is really taking
off at this point and Joe Trippi worked
for Hart in 88 and it was very involved
in the early blogosphere and was very
fascinated by the idea of in fair ways
of this college kid somewhere writing
about how Gary Hart is great that just
seems so incongruous to him then and he
invited me to come out and work on the
Dean campaign to intern for the Dean
campaign that summer which I did now I
had thought that I would that I wanted
to work in politics I actually wanted to
be on campaigns or somehow be involved
in the actual work of politics and what
I learned that year was that I actually
hated working in campaigns and being in
politics I didn't like supporting a
candidate because it meant that to
support them even when they said or did
things that I didn't like not that Dean
did all so many terrible things it's
just I wasn't a hundred percent on that
campaign or any campaign
meanwhile my blog was beginning to take
off people were listening to me the I
was now at hundreds of people a day
occasionally when I got a couple big
links a thousand and I loved it it was
it was really satisfying to me it was
really fascinating to learn about things
and go where my interests wanted to take
me and so that was that was really the
pivot moment in my understanding of my
own career where I went from thinking I
would work in politics to I would write
about it and also recognizing that I was
not built or cut out to support
candidates that that wouldn't be that
wasn't a personality that I had and so
that wasn't gonna work for me in the
long run so if we then flash forward to
say Vox or actually no let's not
approach it that way
what our from that point forward some of
the decisions most important decisions
that helped lead you to where you are
now so a bunch of things happen and
often they relate to not getting
something I wanted so I did not get an
internship at the American Prospect that
I wanted but I but then when I was
panicking I got an internship at the
Washington Monthly which is it wasn't is
a small policy I think now why don't
often publishes now but it's a small
policy magazine out of DC as was the
American Prospect for that matter and
the monthly was an amazing place to do
an internship I mean that's where it's
cemented for me that I wanted to be a
journalist and I was there it was edited
by an is edited by a guy named Paul
glass stris so one it's a very policy
centric place it is a place it is
interested in how government works in
the mechanics of it in the functioning
and quality of the bureaucracy so it
just it takes policy and politics
serious and I think something really
important about the work I've done
including a Vox is I emerge my
background is in the policy blogosphere
and then in the world of policy
magazines all explained and those are
very idiosyncratic world so that used to
be extremely small
and my career as much as anything has
been about expanding the audience for
that kind of coverage
from seeing it as a boutique thing to
seeing it as a mainstream thing and and
that's the thing I think I'm proudest of
doing but so I was at the Washington
Monthly Paul glass to us who is the
editor of it now I believe was yet her
he's fantastic but the two senior
editors and they seemed is so senior to
me now but I realized now they were just
in their twenties but we're Nick confess
or a who is at the New York Times now
and Ben Wallace wells who's at The New
Yorker and both of them are just
extraordinary talented journalists who
were also extraordinary kind to their
interns and actually gave us real work
to do and so I got a sense of what it
would be like to be a journalist so I
didn't get to go to the slightly bigger
place I ended up at the slightly smaller
place and being at the smaller Spade
place it meant I had a lot more contact
with the people working there a lot more
opportunity to do things it was a
fantastic experience I transferred I
didn't really even though I did better
in college I don't really like college
so I thought maybe what I didn't like
was Santa Cruz so I transferred
transferred to UCLA turned out I didn't
like his college don't really like being
at school and my junior year one night I
was sitting up complaining - I was
friend friends with Matt Iglesias at
this point and we were I am so I was
like ASL Matt okay you're too old it is
a I don't know what ASL is I don't know
it is age sex location that's a useful
one yeah not sure it is anymore
yes I think it's now all new Facebook
profile you know but that's what you did
back find me on IRC chat so I'm talking
to tonight I was complaining about I
didn't want to be doing some midterm
paper I was doing and he's like we
should apply for the American prospects
fellowship
I said well I'm a junior so if you have
but but doing it whatever leave college
and I actually looked and it was
possible for me to finish up real to do
enough in the summer that I could
graduate if I needed to so I applied for
the prospects fellowship and I also
applied actually for the New Republic's
reporter researcher position I never got
a call back from the New Republic which
was a certainly more prestigious
magazine at that point so I might have
taken that instead but their reporter
research has actually did a lot more
base level work for the institution so
they did a lot more copy editing in
fact-checking
would have been a much worse job for me
at a place would've been much more
ideologically difficult for me to be at
that point the New Republic was
extremely Pro Iraq war I was quite
against it that by then I wasn't
originally um so it would have been a
very awkward fit but I didn't even get
called back for that so that went
nowhere I did get the American Prospect
job which was amazing and was an the
perfect first job in journalism for me
the next year if I had just done what
was normal the next year the American
Prospect ran out of funding for that job
and it didn't exist so the next year the
only two journalism jobs I had any shot
of getting to because they're their only
ones that cared about bloggers were the
prospect and the New Republic and the
New Republic didn't want me and the
prospect wouldn't be able to take me and
so my whole life could have been
different if I haven't done this in my
junior year and usually so I did that
then I went to the prospect the prospect
was is a great magazine and again it is
part of his small collection of policy
magazines the first thing that happened
to me when I went to the American
Prospect the editor was a guy named Mike
damask II who does a great column for
The Daily Beast now and runs a journal
called democracy but but Mike called me
into his office and he always had his
feet up on his desk and he called me in
and I think this is my first day there a
week there and he says
go find out what's hot in poverty what
he said you know Katrina happened this
is post Katrina this is mm late 2005 and
he says there's a big conversation about
what to do about poverty in this country
go find out what's happening in that
conversation
I don't really now with more experience
recognize that as an article pitch and
and yet it was such a group place where
that could happen in such a great place
one a place it thinks what is hot in
poverty is a sentence it makes sense
right right a lot of places would not
consider there to be such a thing as hot
in the poverty reduction community doula
place it would just send a young
reporter with Mary with really no
experience to learn about that
give them one that became a feature for
them and so my time at the American
Prospect and the third thing that
happened there which is really really
really important and is it was key to my
career is key to my career is I was a
really good blogger I'm willing to say
that at that point in what blogging was
and I was good at that but I didn't know
how to do anything in journalism I
didn't know how to structure an article
I didn't know how to report I didn't
know how to pitch I didn't know anything
now I'd written for you know like op-ed
like columns for the LA week I don't
know a couple little things but I didn't
really have any any skills aside from
write my opinions on the internet
and the American Prospect was a place it
was willing to take me on the strength
of my blogging cuz they were very early
into the blogosphere and wanted to get
some of these young bloggers and in
return for that and for paying me
extremely little teach me how to be a
journalist and he did and they did that
Mike Tomas Kiwi what was the acronym you
just pick up the damn phone
pu TDP he would always say pick up the
damn phone to you and and you learned
okay like one of the tools here is
reporting when you pick up the damn
phone as a blogger you don't expect
anyone would answer your calls because
they probably wouldn't particularly not
at that point but if you're calling from
the american prospect they will and one
of the things was really important in my
career was i was pretty early
emerging the techniques and ideas and
ideologies and sensibility of blogging
with the processes and skills and tools
of journalism and a lot of what I've
been doing in different places is
pulling those two threads together not
in ways that are unique to me but in
ways about many people were doing
because most people who are blogging
were not young enough and free enough to
go take entry-level underpaid jobs where
they could develop these skill sets and
then spend all their time working on
them and most people in journalism did
not want to develop the tools of
blogging because the tools of blogging
were in many ways devout a part partly
in opposition
they were partly based on a critique of
journalism and so my I was in this very
lucky space and I do want to say was a
lucky space it was a product of timing I
happened to start blogging when the wave
began to build and at a moment when
people with hire folks who had that kind
of experience if I had been five years
later five years earlier who [ __ ]
knows
but I also then had the personality to
bring those things together let me ask a
question about that so if you were now
and I don't know how you feel about
teaching as opposed to learning in an
academic setting well let's just say you
had an opportunity to teach a Freshman
Seminar at some type of college to just
a credible set of fifteen students just
really receptive brilliant students that
could change the world and you were
teaching them this combination of well
perhaps it's a writing course for those
who intend to work in politics in some
fashion what would the first what might
be the first lessons or areas of focus
look like like what kind of exercises we
do have them do the first half of the
course would not be about writing at all
one of the criticisms I have of
journalism is that we are too focused
and it's funny because it's a little bit
distinct maybe even contra to what I
just said but we are too focused on
journalism as a universally applicable
skill set tool said now it is that but
because we have so much confidence in it
we do not demand enough subject issue
knowledge out of journalists and the
first half of the course would be about
how to learn how to learn about policies
how to learn about campaigns how to find
the right information sources how to
know what kinds of information are
credible and how to develop a I often
think of my writing as you know as
having sort of an iceberg metaphor any
individual piece is the tip of the
iceberg but the pieces only work because
of what's beneath they work because of
the superstructure of knowledge that
hopefully hopefully if I've done my job
right I've developed over a period of
time the subject matter expertise the
the place where I broke through you
asked earlier about actually breaking
through and and in my head where I work
through K much later the story that I
broke thrown was Obama care and health
care policy generally and the reason I
broke through on it was that long before
it was an issue I had developed an
idiosyncratic interest in it this is
when I was at UCLA on my blog and I just
for no particular reason begun reading
think-tank health care policy proposals
and then I checked out a bunch of books
from the UCLA library and wrote a series
which is probably the most popular thing
I had done until that time called the
health of Nations where I wrote up what
now I think you would characterize
really as Wikipedia summaries of how
does the German healthcare system work
the French health care system the
Canadian Japanese health care systems
and I'd spent all this time over the
next couple of years just writing and
arguing with people about health care
and what that meant was that by the time
it actually became an issue in American
politics to report on I had a very
unusually deep knowledge of health care
policy not health care politics I didn't
have great so
I wasn't the person who could break
stories necessarily but I - really I had
read a lot of Congressional Budget
Office reports a lot more than a lot of
the people who in theory were actually
the folks covering healthcare and so
when that began happening I could
deliver pretty good news reporting and
analysis very fast because when somebody
said something or they release something
I had a model to put it into I
recognized like this is getting a little
bit rambling but but I think this is an
important thing to me someone to ramble
into it anyway one of a core idea of Vox
and a core idea of mine in journal in
how I approach journalism is that the
product is the reporters body of
knowledge not primarily the new piece of
information I think that a lot of
journalism and a lot of reporter
processes workflows approaches etc it is
not a bad thing by the way I just think
there's room for different models it is
all built on finding the next nugget of
news and what people are really good at
and the way stories are structured is to
highlight the next nugget of news and
that that is I do want to be clear
that's an incredibly incredibly
important role that we absolutely need
that but I think kind of everybody was
that I think that's how the whole
industry was when in my view one of the
really important roles that we can play
is to surface and expose the body of
knowledge the model as I think about it
the context that makes that news make
sense to us so a lot of Vox is formats
are explainers our card stacks our
videos our posts we do 15 graphs on
something what we are actually doing
there the the meta point of all that is
that we are building out ways to expose
more of the iceberg more of the
reporter's body of knowledge so that
when we give you a new piece of
information we are laying out more
and more clearly why we understand and
believe that information to be important
and that actually does require you to
think and learn and work in different
ways and and and now connect this a bit
back the thing that I think journals
often don't do enough of is they're so
focused partly when they get moved onto
a beat I'm finding out what's going on
on that bead they don't build enough of
the underlying superstructure they don't
read down the foundational textbooks on
just how does health policy work how
does moral hazard work
how do actuarial rulemaking work and
when you don't do that you you often
cannot communicate policy topics or
complex topics clearly because they're
not actually clear to you right you know
the part that's new people are telling
you which part is new but if it's not if
it doesn't fit really neatly into a
broader structure for you then it's not
gonna come through clearly to the
audience and I think something we do a
lot is we communicate complex topics
unclearly to people and then we blame
them for not getting it totally now and
I want to say there are a tremendous
number of amazing journalists health
care and otherwise who know this stuff
backwards and forwards this is not a
systemic critique but it is something
that happens a lot and it happens
particularly when we just move people
around to beets because we figure the
journalistic toolkit will carry them
through in getting the news and we'll
give them the sources and we'll have the
person reserved before help them when
often I think you actually need to spend
some you almost need to go into a room
for a couple months when I move somebody
on a beat often I will assign them
articles and they're not about something
new but that are about something really
foundational in that area just so they
will have to do the work of learning a
lot of the basic knowledge and the
article it's not gonna break any new
ground but I'll know at the end of it
they have that well this this makes me
think of Sebastian Junger also who said
to me once I asked him how he dealt with
writer's block and he said writer's
block just means I don't have the ammo
he said I and I'm paraphrasing here but
you never want to fix a gap in your
research with a cute twist of prose and
you just need to do more research and I
and I will this is a bit of a different
episode than a lot of my
so we'll I'll dive into it I will make
it a systemic critique so I will go
there because I have an inch deep rooted
insecurities about feeling ignorant of
politics and it's been largely by choice
because I felt like I can't distinct the
I can't distinguish oftentimes theater
and posturing from fact I don't know how
to find what is reliable and what is not
I mean I have a few ideas but the point
being that when I ask sometimes the dumb
questions in say at dinners because
something has been unclear to me I often
do get sort of a side eye from I'm not
going to name names but people in the
media who have presented it themselves
in a very unclear way and so one of the
questions I wanted to ask you is you
know I'm not the smartest guy but I feel
like I could maybe wade through this and
figure at least establish a basic
understanding of how this democracy and
government that we live under functions
but I imagine it being like reading the
IRS tax code and just being impenetrable
text so for someone who said you know
what I'm actually not only relatively
historically uninterested in politics
I've actively avoided it but I feel like
I want to understand how this machine
works
what books or resources what approach
would you recommend if I don't if I'm
not going to make it a twenty hour a
week thing so aside from reading box
aside from reading facts good because
let me say a couple things because
everything you said there I think is
right on and it breaks my heart my
foundational experience the the thing
that I've always been trying to correct
is after 9/11 when I began reading the
news I remember that I would read pieces
and I think I only understood 45 percent
of that so many of the terms or names
that were encoded with meaning didn't
mean anything to me so Senate Minority
Leader Tom Daschle I didn't know much
about the Senate I don't really know
what the Minority Leader does I don't
know anything about Tom Daschle but he's
the key character yeah so I am NOT
getting this and I remember slowly I was
like now it's 55% and then it was 65 and
then it was 75 and now it's a hundred
and forty because there's a lot of stuff
that just isn't in the article at all
but I'm able to see and I remember
a very experienced editor one saying to
me it took me ten years to learn how to
read a newspaper story and he met that
is like I'm great I've learned how we
are [ __ ] up if it needs ten years of
training to learn what's going on here
and understand like the game behind the
game the story behind the story so a
couple things this is we have an
internal document at Vox called the Vox
voice about well who are we supposed to
be to the audience and one of the
premises here is it if we have maids if
we have taken something important and
made it uninteresting it is always our
fault and it is never theirs that is the
idea that you know it's interesting the
[ __ ] IRS tax code I have written
about that a lot it is a fascinating
place that is a place where we translate
a lot of our values and ideas as a
country into actual policy and the
stories encoded and that are fascinating
but we often don't write them well so in
terms of how do you do this the first
thing I would say is that it is helpful
to find guides it is helpful to find
people whose tone whose sensibility
whose approach you connect to we it's
often said that people think in stories
but I also think that they prefer to
think through social relationships and
if you are able to build a relationship
an intellectual relationship with Matt
Iglesias or Paul Krugman or Ross Douthat
or Rebecca tracer or Annie Lowry my wife
is an amazing economics reporter I think
that actually helps that's that's why
blogging was really good for me because
there were these people who I connected
to and even when I didn't understand
exactly what they were saying I had this
relationship with him that carried me
through the second thing that I do think
is important and this might be me
talking through how I think but it's
really helpful for me to be writing now
comment sections are a bit of a dying
thing online but Twitter isn't and
Facebook threads aren't and I think
there's a lot of [ __ ] talking about all
these terrible political Facebook
friends or nobody knows anything but you
know what writing half informed comments
about politics on Facebook that is a
legitimate form of engagement in a way
that you
learn about political life and then I do
think I really think this has gotten
better
I really fundamentally at my soul
believe this has gotten better I think
that in the last ten years both a number
of outlets again I really think like Fox
but also a number of traditional outlets
who used to be much more mannered and
buttoned up and for the experts have
opened up their writing styles a lot and
made it a lot easier to read what
they're doing let me jump in just
because I feel like you are one of the
people I've developed somewhat of a
relationship with so I want to lean on
you since I've I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna delve into it with a lot of time
on the internet because I'm just a verse
to it for a lot of reasons but my
primary interest I'll just tell you is
that I've worked on a few specific
things meaning legislation and in a
number of states related to say like
shark of an importation and some other
things which have actually proven
effective but outside of that my
interest in politics is I guess twofold
now at this point one is that it's
become clear to me you can be a great
chess player but it's it's on some level
much more interesting if you are able to
influence the rules of chess itself so I
have I feel an obligation to gain a
better understanding of how it works
also from an intellectual standpoint so
if there any books that ain't a someone
who has been actively avoiding politics
for a long time would read that could
increase my level of understanding that
would be amazing then the second thing
and we may not have time for it today
cuz this is gonna wrap up in just a few
minutes so we'll probably do a follow on
is my interest is in active change and
and I remember I was told once I'm not
gonna name the person but the right-hand
man of a very well-known politician said
to me he said because I was talking to
him about this and he said just imagine
that you have maybe maximum six bullets
per year you get to shoot six and what I
see on the internet is a I don't want to
engage in any religious war
conversations over politics where no one
is going to change their mind it's a
waste of my time I don't want to engage
in dialogue where the end product is not
going to be change for the better of
some type so for me I want to figure out
how I can pick my shots and using the
assets that I have and so on doesn't
mean becoming a political writer which I
don't want to do how I can influence the
rules of the game right and I've one of
the chip well then meandering a bit but
part of the challenge that I have is
that I get hit with so many asks I get
hit with hundreds of asks for different
propositions this I mean when I did
stand up for and unfortunately passed
was the the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act way back in the day I
had a long conversation with Daniel
Ellsberg some of you may know from
Pentagon Papers about this and went
public with it I didn't change the
course of history
but I also alienated half of my audience
immediately and I'm trying to figure out
how to how to play with all those
factors but it seems to start with at
least figuring out what the [ __ ] is
going on and how it actually works what
are your thoughts so a couple things in
terms of books and I should do more
thinking on this in the book that is
probably the most influential for me in
thinking about how American politics
really works is not the easiest read but
it's a book by a political scientist
named Francis Lee called beyond ideology
and the basic argument of this book
which is very and if you want a
condensed version of it I actually wrote
a New Yorker piece called the
unpersuaded which leans on this book
very cleverly okay so you can you can
read that too but this book what it
shows is that a lot of our intuition
about politics which is that when the
president comes out and leads on an
issue that is how things get done is
flatly wrong that actually we have a
system in which governmental power is
usually divided it's very very easy to
block things and usually you have
different parties controlling things
when the president talks about anything
the chance of the other party polarizing
against it automatically becomes higher
and she is this great dataset where she
uses non-controversial issues and shows
that whenever the president talks about
a non-controversial issue an issue where
the two parties don't have positions
like should
we fly up rocketship to Mars the
president talking about it leads to a
sharp increase in party line vote so
there's a lot of good information in
some of those books the gamble which is
by a series of political scientists on
the 2012 election I think is really
helpful it's a guy named Bob Edwards
who's written a series of books on
presidential rhetoric those those are
books of it they're not the friendliest
tours through American politics but they
are the most information rich that come
to mind immediately so that's one thing
the other I do not think there's a way
to invest in politics aggressively that
will not lead to some controversy these
are things or disagreement Israel but I
will say that people over invest in the
headline issues they are unlikely to
change minds on issues where everybody
already has a very intense position
where there is a lot of room and
politics to change things is to raise
the salience of issues that people do
not currently care a lot about so I
think that something that I and others
have tried to do over last couple years
is raises silient is raise the salience
of the filibuster as an issue that is
important in American politics that
people should care about more and that
actually has changed the filibuster has
it has weakened a little bit my friend
Matt Iglesias and others have been very
aggressive Ryan Avent and others in
talking about housing density zoning
policies occupational licensing these
are city level policies that people
weren't really thinking of as big
problems in the American growth story
ten years ago but I think are now
developing an appreciation for them and
neither party is practically polarized
on them in fact there's a lot of
agreement so just by raising them as
issues there's been I think a lot more
opportunity to get things done so did
the extent that you can take people and
convince them to care about something
new where maybe the battle lines and
American politics are not already
extremely drawn that can be very very
powerful so if I were you thinking about
this I would be not looking to weigh in
on somewhere where there is
already a raging war but to weigh in
somewhere where maybe people haven't
thought about this or maybe they under
ate the importance of it but would be
open to deciding that this should be
higher on their priority list because
that can be a very powerful thing and
this there can still be the chance to
create an equilibrium around it that is
non polarized so I definitely wanna have
more conversation with you about this
I'm gonna do some reading first this I'm
not a complete idiot and just but we're
gonna wrap up in a minute but I'll tell
you another reason why or another moment
when I actually became more interested
in this as a skill set and I wanted very
much develop a toolkit for myself so
that I can pick my shots maybe involve
my audience maybe not but I my TED talk
which which at the end closes with a
discussion of education reform really
delve into it for a number of years and
looked at public school education the
u.s. spent a ton of time I met with some
lawmakers and I remember at one point
being really just beating down and
exhausted involved teachers unis this
that and the other thing and I won't
point with the details but I ended up
having lunch with the senator and he
said to me look a lot of people come out
of say entrepreneurship business look at
ballet they think they've figured out
how to do one thing they come in here
they try to change it and they get
chewed up and spit out by this
bureaucracy they don't make any lasting
change he said perhaps what you should
think about and he wasn't talking about
himself but he said I hate to put it
this way but perhaps you should just
raise a bunch of funds and buy yourself
a loving meaning the support and
whatever it might be campaigning and so
on and I thought to myself a I was
thankful to this guy so we'd actually
have spent quite a bit of time together
I was like for just like saying how it
is if that's how it is and then be
that's a [ __ ] up that's horrible and
really depressing and see if that's the
way it actually is I need to learn how
to deal with that I have a couple
thoughts on this okay and so and then
we'll wrap up in you and we'll do a
follow on because we have so much more
so
number one money in politics is toxic
and it is poisonous and you can hear it
right there it erodes trust in the
system and it doesn't work like that
it is not impossible to bribe your way
into some kind of political outcome but
it is quite difficult partically
anything that people are thinking about
and hearing about now I know used to be
clear mouthing about bribes no I know
but I think the way people imagine that
going when you say by a politician is
that you give the politician X amount of
dollars or you fund a super PAC for them
and then you know basically there's
money changing hands so that they will
vote a certain way on an issue on some
issues where practically issues that are
more or less out of the public eye that
stuff does happen on the big issues
polarization party incentives electoral
incentives are just much more powerful
and I'll just say this year has been a
powerful way of thinking about what
money can and can't buy because across
all of the elections Jeb Bush was the
best funded Republican Hillary Clinton
was by far the better funded general
election challenger money it is a bad
thing in American politics there's
almost no version of campaign finance
room you can propose it I won't support
but I think people over eight its power
so let me give you a different twist on
that though the thing people really
underestimate and really under invest in
is city and state politics tremendous
amounts of change can happen there
tremendously important things can begin
there and there's a lot less
polarization a lot less opportunity to
access your legislators or the other
relevant decision-makers and a lot of
opportunity then for things just spread
so I mean you think about the way in
which marijuana is being legalized
slowly but surely across the country
that is beginning in states he wouldn't
be able to fight it in Congress first
but by starting in a couple of states
are able to have a national impact and
one thing if I could change the way
people if I could change anything the
way people engage with politics there's
actually a probably good thing to say I
wish people thought less about the
President and more about Congress and
less about national politics and more
about state and local politics I think
at every level we tend to try to default
to treating Paul
like an episode of The West Wing where
the president is a main character than
all these other supporting characters
and the question is can he make us
Turing enough speech that isn't how it
works
and that also isn't where most of our
power is individually look you live in a
big state California is an important
place where California goes oftentimes
so too does the nation and you have a
much and also you have the insane
totally [ __ ] up California ballot
proposition process which for all of its
problems does create a much easier
access point to potentially hosting very
very large experiments that maybe the
political system would not want to host
normally so I would think less about
Congress and more about the place you
actually live with people who will
actually listen to you who don't have as
many folks wanting for their attention
and who maybe actually have a little bit
more space to run because of it all
right guys I'm gonna do a bunch more
thinking on this I'm going to try to get
over my lifelong allergy to the word and
the concept and all of the dinner brawls
that I witness to my relatives having to
actually figure out how this works and
do some good so to be continued as
you're aware can people find you connect
with you and so on so on the Internet's
at voxcom
that is our our website and it has all
the normal social media manifestations
you'd expect i'm on twitter at
twitter.com/zeromd Glacia stand center
cliff every week and then the Ezra Klein
show where I do long interviews with
very smart people and I'll try one one
closing question if you could put short
message on a gigantic billboard to get a
message out to millions of people what
would it be so I actually I thought
about this question when you've asked it
before my belief in the persuade ability
of people is extremely low I think it is
very hard to persuade anybody of
anything particularly if you can only do
it drive by so I'm not gonna try to
persuade anybody with my billboard but
it put a billboard to somewhere on the
405 where there's a lot of traffic and
I'm going to find somebody more visual
the creative than me to create a
billboard that brings a little bit of
wonder and happiness and levity into a
long shitty drive that people have to do
every day maybe it'll just say you're
almost there I like it I like it that's
actually that's a very good one you're
almost there
Ezra thank you so much man I give them a
really fun and to be continued this this
is going to be a offline or online for
the podcast or not for the podcast so
you guys let us know let me know I will
have a lot of follow-up questions and
ver be listening you can certainly find
the show notes everywhere doesn't make
any sense at all you can find the show
notes on everything we talked about at
4-hour workweek comport slash podcast as
per usual and as always thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday the vet
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by four
sig Matic I reached out to these
innovative Finnish entrepreneurs of all
things because a very skilled Acrobat
introduced me to one of their products
which is a mushroom coffee made out of
chaga mushroom powerful antioxidant
considered a superfood I was introduced
to chaga by Laird Hamilton of all people
and another mushroom called lion's mane
which is considered
no tropic or a smart drug and I had half
a packet let me put this in perspective
tasted just like coffee just add the hot
water only twenty milligrams in half a
packet of Cappy and that's it's as
little as 1/10 what you would find in a
strong cup of coffee and I was on fire
for the entire day I probably got more
done in that day than I got done in the
three or four days prior to that so I
would highly recommend checking it out
it is very impressive you will not see
visuals so you can use it for work and
you can check it out at four sigma tech
comm forward slash tim that's four sig
Matic si GM ATI c-calm forward slash Tim
and use the code Tim to get 20% off your
first order I highly encourage you to
try it out this episode is brought to
you by fresh books back in 2003 a busy
freelancer named Mike Dermot but I've
actually had dinner with accidentally
saved over an invoice and lost all of
his work to make sure that never
happened again Mike set out to create
fresh books which is now the number one
cloud accounting software designed
exclusively for self-employed
professionals around the world that is
used by now 10 million plus folks in
total who need to send invoices get paid
fast and track the time a lot of you
fall in that category in September of
this year Mike and his entire team
relaunched an all-new version of their
platform built from the ground up double
down on what made a great in first place
namely simplicity and speed so I can't
cover all the features in this
particular sponsor read but you can send
a branded invoice in under 30 seconds
you can see what a client is looked at
their invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support you will get a real
human being on the phone in three rings
for less and there are many other things
you can take pictures of receipts on
your phone using their iOS mobile app
and makes expenses a million times
easier etc etc it is a rad service a lot
of you have recommended to me that's how
this came to be as a sponsorship so to
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial that means no credit card needed
and
see how the brand-new FreshBooks can
change your freelancing game go to
FreshBooks comm forward slash Tim and
enter Tim T I am in the how did you hear
about a section that is first ebooks.com
forward slash tip
[Applause]